[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the impact that eternals will have on
the mcu will be nothing less than
redefining the cinematic universe
entirely
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have our first official clip an
actual scene from the eternals and it is
a heck of a scene if this is any
indication on what the entire movie is
going to be like then this movie is
going to be absolutely phenomenal and as
you heard kevin feige talking and like i
mentioned before this movie is going to
be extremely important to the mcu moving
forward they are literally introducing
cosmic entities up close and personal in
this film we have some new clips of
athena fighting and we have learned a
little bit more about thena thanks to
some interviews that have been happening
with the cast of the eternals and the
director chloe zao we knew that fina had
a secret before and it looks like maybe
athena herself doesn't even know about
that secret and of course there is just
a ton of hype right now on what the two
post-credit scenes for the film could be
and it is confirmed that there will be
two post-credits scenes now we're gonna
break all of this down in this video and
if you want to stay up to date on the
eternals and catch my reaction after i
see it at the premiere on monday be sure
to subscribe and hit the notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos so based off of what we've
seen so far with the eternals this clip
right here seems to be probably the
first clip of the movie the opening
scene we have seen a scene where the
eternals are kind of asleep and then
they awaken and that probably happens
right before this scene right here right
before they go to earth now once they
get to earth it's very clear what
happens the ship arrives and the people
see the ship and then the eternals
descend from the ship it shows to us a
little kid and we see the little kid
looking up at the descending eternals in
which then icarus begins to fight with a
deviant now in the comics the eternals
were tasked with protecting the earth
from the deviants and it looks like that
might be pretty similar in the film it
looks like the eternals could possibly
be sent to earth by the celestials
because right when they show up to earth
they are fighting the deviants so it is
possible that the celestial sent them
there to take care of the deviant
problem also not to mention we know that
crow is going to be the main villain of
this film and he is going to be in
charge of the deviants perhaps he was on
a different planet before but just
recently came to earth and that's why
the celestials sent the eternals to
earth and once they get there they
immediately begin doing an amazing job
at protecting the humans from the
deviants icarus begins to take on one of
the deviants just by himself and we've
seen a clip of him in another trailer
punching the deviant basically killing
him
now icarus is one of the strongest
eternals each of them kind of have
similar powers the ability to manipulate
cosmic energy but as we saw in the
latest featurette some of their powers
slightly differ for example icarus has
the ability to shoot cosmic energy out
of his eyes much like superman now back
to the clip the kid is still watching
icarus obviously these godlike beans
just descended from the air and started
fighting monsters i wouldn't be able to
take my eyes off of it either but he is
unaware of the deviant coming up behind
him to kill him but luckily lauren
ridloff's makari is there to save the
child using her individual unique power
the power of super speed so again most
of them have the same abilities but they
all each have at least one individual
ability now makari with her super speed
doesn't just save this one child she
begins to evacuate everybody else around
so they don't get killed by the deviant
we can actually see the deviant get back
up and start snapping at people but
makari is moving them out of the way and
getting them far away from danger
meanwhile kamil nanjiani's kingo comes
and starts to help in the battle we see
him harness cosmic energy and use it as
projectile blast kind of shooting it out
of his fingertips like their guns it
hits the deviant back a little bit and
then makari comes in and hits it with
the force of her super speed which
knocks it back then we see kingo
harnessing the cosmic energy in a
different way it doesn't just come out
of his fingertips he kind of focuses it
into a ball between his hands and he
kind of does a little kamehameha and
shoots it at the deviant this shows his
mastery of cosmic energy being able to
use it as projectile blast then after
ghost signs to makari nice move in which
she signs back you too and if you
haven't caught on by now makari the
character is actually deaf and she's
actually being played by a deaf actress
lauren ridloff so it's pretty awesome to
see now the nice move thing is really
cool to see how close the eternals are
but i also think that this could be
because they haven't actually fought in
a very long time if they truly were
asleep before arriving to earth who
knows how long they could have been
asleep for they could have been asleep
and sort of just sitting there until the
celestials decided that it was time to
use them clearly they knew each other
before because they are able to sign to
each other so it makes you really wonder
about their backstory which of course
the movie is going to go into now we
also do have new clips of athena in
action
of course played by the wonderful
angelina jolie thena is the warrior of
the group she harnesses her cosmic
energy into weapons now in the trailers
and the clips that we've seen so far
we've actually seen her turn her cosmic
energy into several different weapons
we've seen a spear a sword an axe we've
also seen her dual wield dagger type
weapons and we've actually seen her use
two different types of weapons at once a
few times during all of these clips and
trailers now we recently learned from
marvel a little bit about angelina
jolie's character athena as it turns out
she's going to have somewhat of a
disability in the movie according to
marvel producer nate moore she's going
to have something called mod warai and
i'm sure i didn't pronounce that right
but basically it's described as a
version of dementia he said in an
interview with screenrant she has a
tragic story in our film in that she
comes down with something called mod
would rai if you guys are fans of comics
mod would rai is something that can be
set an internal it's a version of
dementia because of the amount of
memories they have they become unstuck
in their own mind so she starts to
forget exactly when she is so through
the course of the movie gilgamesh
becomes a protector and when we find
them in the modern day they're living
off the grid in a cabin in australia
because she's too dangerous to have
around humans so it's a fun arc for
angelina to play this is actually pretty
revealing about her character now in the
comics sprite using his power in the
comics because in the comics spread as a
guy makes all of the eternals forget who
they are takes away their powers and
removes all records of them from reality
now obviously the eternals have lived
for 7 000 years they say that in the
comics and obviously that is a lot of
memories to kind of keep inside of your
mind so yes reality could get rather
confusing if you had a lot of memories
to store however we know that thena
actually has a pretty big secret and in
the comics her big secret is that she
actually has a kid or twins with a
deviant and guess who that deviant was
crow the very same person that we see in
the trailers talking to athena so i'm
guessing that the secret of theena is
that she actually had children with crow
and perhaps maybe one of the other
eternals or maybe a celestial has caused
her to forget this on purpose but
obviously as we've seen in the trailers
her and crow are going to come face to
face so all of this is probably going to
come out into the open and i'm guessing
that she's probably going to remember
everything by the end of the movie and
then of course if you haven't heard
director chloe zao has confirmed that
there are going to be two post-credit
scenes and she said that they are both
going to be extremely important moving
forward in the mcu and of course we just
heard kevin feige talk about how much
the eternals is going to redefine the
mcu so if the eternals is not something
that you're excited for yet i would get
very excited about it because it's going
to be a huge movie and will most likely
set up some major things for the future
of the mcu but let me know what you
think about this clip in the comments
down below and let me know what you
think about thena's disability and her
secret don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof